[Music]
deep space nine gets a commanding shout
out in the second episode of star trek
picard as the new season makes
references to time travel and mirror
universe episodes of series past here
are all the easter eggs you missed
when cue first appears at the close of
the premiere the stargazer actor john
delancey appears digitally de-aged as
the younger version we've seen before in
the next generation and voyager
he's back
but upon seeing picard in his advanced
years q snaps his fingers and becomes
his older equal this mirrors most of q's
prior appearances in which he tended to
change his appearance to suit the
situation or his own whims but other
littler homages are sprinkled throughout
q's first meeting with jean-luc in
season 2. on cue's chest fans will note
a black brooch with a design that is
nearly identical to the red and gold
pendant he wore in his earliest
appearances on star trek the next
generation a clear callback to days gone
by likewise his dialogue includes
several fourth wall breaking moments
such as when he references yesterday's
enterprise the title of a classic tmg
episode where the crew of the stargazer
oh a queen a provincial how yesterday's
enterprise have you when introducing
picard to the altered reality he's
created he says the words through a
mirror darkly a phrase from alice in
wonderland that was previously used in
trex series past to refer to the mirror
universe a parallel reality that is very
similar to what we see in star trek
picard several episodes set in the
mirror universe reference the passage
including the enterprise episode in a
mirror darkly and the deep space nine
episode through the looking glass
as q gives picard a brief tour of who he
is in this new bizarre altered reality
he leads him into his trophy room which
is packed with easter eggs and
references to the wider star trek
franchise one of the first things we see
is a cardassian military uniform as well
as the armor of the klingon torchbearer
seen in star trek discovery a number of
phase rifles disrupters and alien
weapons hang on the wall but the most
exciting references come with picard's
collection of skulls yes skulls among
the many lives that picard has taken is
gull ducat the villainous cardassian who
antagonized captain cisco on deep space
nine according to q picard killed him
during a brutal fight that resulted in
this version of picard needing a
synthetic body next we see the skinned
head of general martok the klingon
warrior from deep space nine who was
killed in armed combat after a
bioengineered virus decimated the
klingon homeworld the vulcan cerex skull
is also shown upon a pedestal with the
ambassador said to have been decapitated
by picard on the steps of the vulcan
science academy in front of his own wife
and son an obvious reference to spock a
ferengi skull also shown is likely the
grand nagis as his traditional
gold-tipped staff is seen mounted
beneath it
though not a mirror universe episode the
dark reality created by q is as close to
it as we've gotten for an adventure of
jean-luc picard who never visited the
mirror universe during tng the portrait
of picard as a war hero clad in all
black and the confederation as an
organization of anti-alien conquerors
feels straight out of the original
series episode mirror mirror in the star
trek enterprise episode in a mirror
darkly we even got a twisted darker
opening sequence that turned the series
upbeat intro on its head subverting its
message of hope and optimism into one of
fascism and war in the second episode of
star trek picard season 2 we get
something similar a message from this
dark picard giving an inverted version
of the classic star trek narration
instead of seeking out new life and new
civilizations and boldly going where no
one had gone before this picard sought
out and subjugated savage civilizations
boldly conquered warlike alien worlds
increased the wealth and resources for
future generations of humanity at the
end of the message this evil iteration
of picard even gives a similar gesture
that he was known for on the next
generation when giving his order to
engage but this time rather than waving
to his helmsman the sign to go to warp
picard is pointing to potential soldiers
and encouraging them to join the fight
against alien worlds
in the dark reality we learn that seven
of nine was never assimilated by the
borg and as annika hansen has become the
president of earth finding herself
married to a man she's never met she
attempts to play the part until she can
figure out what's going on she's asked
by her husband who is also a
high-ranking administrator in the earth
government the status of the war on the
vulcan front and she brings up a display
that gives her the details on the screen
we see that image of rios now a colonel
in the confederation fighting near
vulcan which is labeled in parentheses
as nevar fans of star trek discovery
will recall that in the far future where
the series is now set the planet vulcan
had been reunified with their romulan
cousins and changed their homeworld's
name to navarre to reflect that its use
here may suggest that in this reality
the vulcans and romulans have similarly
unified this seems to be supported by
the image of a romulan bird of prey
engaged in battle with the la sirena
elsewhere on the view screen but the
deepest of cuts comes when one pauses to
read the description of ryosa's mission
as the confederation is preparing to
deploy a devastating weapon called the
metreon cascade this is the same weapon
of mass destruction that was at the
center of the star trek voyager episode
jetrel and used on the planet rynax in
the war between the tilaxians and the
hikonian order how the confederation got
their hands on a weapon from the delta
quadrant remains a mystery during this
scene seven of nine is also offered a
meeting with general cisco this
alternate reality's version of deep
space nine captain benjamin cisco it's
the first on-screen reference to the
character in more than 20 years since he
left to join with the prophets in the
series finale of his series sadly it's
unlikely cisco will turn up on star trek
picard as actor avery brooks hasn't
performed on screen since 2001.
nevertheless it's good to know that
cisco is out there in this or any other
universe
after q changes history and alters
reality into a dark version of the world
they know picard seven rios rafi elenor
and jaradi all wake up without any
knowledge of what has happened the last
thing they remember was the borg's
attack on the bridge of the stargazer
and a sudden flash of light jaradi comes
two in a laboratory and is greeted to
the sarcastic comments of an
artificially intelligent program that's
taken the form of an animated cat i am
spot 73 your
very best friend of course calling
itself spot 73 this cartoon kitten will
surely evoke memories of another cat in
star trek lore named spot data's beloved
pet feline on star trek the next
generation as gerardi worked on the
project to recreate data's positronic
brain in the original timeline it's
entirely possible that she did the same
in this new one and that spot 73's
creation was an ode to data's cat's spot
of course this isn't the first time
we've seen artificially intelligent pets
created by anti-social genius inventors
in star trek way back in the star trek
voyager episode lifeline dr louis
zimmerman the brilliant engineer who
created the emergency medical hologram
kept several holographic pets including
an iguana named leonard and even a
housefly named roy
when the trailers for star trek picard
season 2 first dropped many fans noticed
a key shot of rios's ship the la sirena
flying very close to the sun combined
with the time travel nature of the story
on display many began speculating that
the sequence shown might be the ship
using a classic trek trope the slingshot
effect to travel back in time first seen
in star trek the original series during
episode tomorrow is yesterday it
requires advanced computer calculations
with the aid of a highly intelligent
co-pilot to achieve a time warp effect
by flying close to a star and
slingshotting around it it was used
again by captain kirk in the episode
assignment earth and a third time in the
film star trek iv the voyage home based
on the second episode of its second
season it seems that star trek picard
will make use of the slingshot effect
again here picard proposes using it to
travel back in time to fix whatever cue
is done to alter the timeline even
mentioning kirk by name and how he used
the maneuver to visit the past
kirk's enterprise did it on more than
one occasion however without spock to
calculate the variable and with seven of
nine no longer an ex-borg who might be
able to fill in they need another
high-minded intellect to help them in a
twist of fate picard enlists the aid of
the borg queen who is a prisoner of the
confederation in this reality check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]